[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui je suis dans l'espace richo
à Versailles nous y étions il y a un an
avec Arnaud Adami un jeune peintre et
aujourd'hui j'ai la joie de retrouver di
Benoît Duray toujours dans cette
politique de la ville de soutien aux
jeunes artistes émergents donc son
exposition démarre le 20 octobre
jusqu'au 3 décembre Diane benoî dururay
bonjour bonjour c'est ça le date c'est
bon oui c'est ça génial voilà donc
espace richot à Versailles alors j'ai
envie de faire connaissance avec vous
jeune artiste peintre vous quand est-ce
que le dessin est arrivé dans votre vie
alors je dois dire assez tôt
je crois que je dessine depuis à peu
près tout toujours en fait ouais mais de
manière
très comment dire inconsciente voilà
voilà du gribouillage je suis passé du
gribouillage à l'imitation de bande
dessiné que j'avais chez moi dans dans
l'apprentissage du dessin et puis après
je vais continuer le enfin voilà
vocabulaire là en fait des cours d'acc
il y a des artistes dans votre famille
pas du tout pas du tout vous êtes là de
versaill on peut
vous avez habité
versaill et vous avez pris des cours au
beauzzard de versaill pour démarrer
voilà et après vous avez continué votre
formation à Strasbourg c'était quoi
cette école donc c'est l'école des alors
anciennement les arts décoratifs
aujourd'hui elle s'intitule La
HM et voilà c'est un cursus en 5 ans
donc deux diplômes diplôme à la fin de
la 3e année et à la fin de la 5e année
et c'est à ce moment-là que vous dites
je vais en faire mon métier je vais être
peintre
alors de métier peintre oui plutôt je
savais que je voulais être artiste enfin
déjà au moment de de passer les concours
et et de rentré en l' école d'art la
peinture c'est venue effectivement à
l'école d'accord et qu'est-ce qui a
déclenché disons que pendant la
formation les deux premières années les
deux trois premières années on touche à
beaucoup de choses très différentes
l'idée c'est vraiment de voilà le que
les que les étudiants puissent découvrir
beaucoup de choses très variées donc moi
j'ai j'ai travaillé le verre par exemple
ouais en 3è année donc j'ai vraiment
soufflé du vert il y a un atelier vert
du coup aux artéco j'ai fait du design
euh voilà on a touché à beaucoup de
choses il y a une section illustration
graphisme tout toutes les sections euh
artisan enfin artisanales dans sens euh
voilà le la le travail de la céramique
du bois du métal tout ça et euh et en
fait assez naturellement et accompagné
par les professeurs c'est vrai que
j'avais déjà euh une une une sensibilité
à la à la couleur et à la matière de la
peinture qui fait que je me suis dirigée
euh assez enfin en 3e année en
fait dans la section peinture d'accord
et il y a une une interview de vous où
vous dites à un moment je me suis sentie
légitime en tant que peintre ça veut
dire quoi se sentir légitime en tant que
peintre bah alors je dirais que disons
que quand on se lance dans ce métier-là
euh on peut ressentir je va pas parler
au nom de tout on peut ressentir
le le poids de l'histoire de l'art
disons voilà des des des très grands
artistes très grands techniciens tout ça
le et puis la difficulté effectivement
de vivre de de ce
métier et euh et je sais pas et puis
même même par rapport à sa famille ou
son son entourage proche de je sais pas
de montrer que que techniquement on est
capable de faire pas mal de choses tout
ça il y a un peu il y a un peu ça je
dirais dans en tout cas moi dans mon
apprentissage voilà le savoir-faire le
fait de de du coup montrer qu'on est pas
là par hasard que euh qu'on a qu'on a
une vraie base technique tout ça donc
moi je l'ai travaillé effectivement
pendant tout pendant toutes ces années
et euh et donc a un moment donné où on
dépasse un peu cette question là où on
comprend assez vite que ce qui est plus
intéressant c'est finalement
euh voilà qui on est qu'est-ce qu'on
veut dire notre identité derrière ça
enfin j'imagine que si vous peignez pas
ça va pas très bien donc il voilà il y a
le moyen et puis le et puis la la la
finalité je dirais et donc la finalité
c'est une recherche constante de toute
une vie d'artiste de savoir ce qu'on a
envie d'exprimer qu'est-ce qu'on a
qu'est-ce qui nous intéresse vraiment
qu'est-ce qu'on a au fond no nos trip et
le le le moyen après ça peut être
beaucoup de choses voilà comme comme la
technique le support le toutes les
recherches diverses et varié OK et voilà
donc la question du sujet elle est
devenue très central à un moment donné
pour moi dans mon parcours au-delà de
savoir voilà dessiner ou peindre c'est
bon ben une fois que c'est c'est à quiis
c'est bon après on avance oui et
dites-moi euh on va parler de votre
travail actuel évidemment de cette
exposition avant d'en arriver à cet
abstrait à cette recherche sur la
lumière la couleur vous avez démarré
comment alors bah du coup moi j'ai
démarré vraiment premières œuvres en
fait c'est ça l'idée alors les premières
œuvres que je n'ai pas je n'ai pas gardé
qu'on ne verra jamais qu'on ne verra
jamais vraiment je travaillais des
portraits des personnages qui
m'entourait à ce moment-là portrait
paysage je me suis confronté un peu à
ces deux genes TR très classiques
touours avec le côté technique savoir
faire finalement voà et et là qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé bah en fait je dirais
que par exemple quand je peignais des
portraits h ce qui me venait assez
naturellement c'était de faire des fonds
très abstrait très uni en fait pour
mettre en valeur aussi le le sujet du
personnage sujet
euh et je sentais bien que le fond avait
autant d'importance que que que le sujet
à ce moment-là et je prenais beaucoup de
plaisir que j'allais vous demander vous
preniez plus de plaisir à à établir les
fonds finalement qu'à qu'à faire
apparaître les les sujets je en fait je
dirais que c'était c'était deux manières
d'aborder le le travail de
représentation différente c'està dire
que quand on est dans le sujet h il peut
y avoir quelque chose donc de plus
laborieux dans le travail de la
représentation de la la recherche de la
ressemblance tout ça ouis on s'applique
entre guillemets très contrôlé
exactement dans le geste alors que le
fond du coup on est complètement en
dehors de de ce type de considération li
ouais plus libre et du coup j'avais la
sensation de d'être plus proche de la
matière de la peinture en fait de ce
qu'elle pouvait raconter de tout d'un
coup je sais pas c'est très technique
mais plus on l' dilu plus plus elle
devient évanescente plus du coup on sent
la toile derrière enfin optiquement il
se passe des choses très très
différentes en fonction de la manière de
l'appliquer en fonction du geste en
fonction du pinceau vous travaillez au
pinceau et vous travaillez l'huile on
est d'accord c'est ça voilà ok donc on
en arrive finalement il y a un jour vous
vous êtes dit j'oublie le sujet j'oublie
alors vous avez vous dites j'abandonne
les
prétextes en fait je l'ai ça s'est fait
progressivement je dirais
que au début quand quand on parle des
des personnages tout d'un coup euh ces
ces sujetsl sont très conditionné
c'estàdire que on se dit ah bah tiens
c'est une personne qui vit à telle
époque de tel il y a beaucoup de codes
en fait qui qui qui fige aussi le le
sujet c'est V que je suis passée avant
de passer de la figurationabstraction je
suis passée déjà à des sujets qui
étaient plus abstraits c'est-à-dire que
par
exemple au lieu de peindre voilà au lieu
de peindre un personnage je pouvait
peindre un mannequin en plastique c'est
dire c'est c'est idé plus de la figure
humaine que vraiment quelque chose voilà
de figé et pareil je pouvais peindre des
petites natures mortes mais c'était des
petits objets très abstraits en fait je
comprends et ceux ces objets là
commençaient à devenir du coup des
prétextes à appliquer des sensations de
lumière des projections de lumière
dessus ou de couleur ah c'est ça le
prétexte voilà et et après j'ai j'ai
petit à petit en fait j'ai radicalisé en
fait mon le le travail en me disant mais
vraiment ce qui m'intéresse c'est c'est
plutôt ce travail de lumière et de
couleur et de couleur ok donc on l'a dit
vous peignez au pinceau vous peignez à
l'huile donc cet expo là qui qui a lieu
en ce moment à l'espace récha il y a une
dizaine de toiles plutôt des grands
formats comme on peut voir autour de
nous et elles sont issues de de séries
que vous avez réalisé comment vous avez
abordé la l'exposition dans un tel lieu
parce que là on n'est pas dans la White
Box rectangulaire des des galerie
traditionnelle c'est ça provoque quoi
chez vous bah alors c'est vrai que la
première visite ça é un petit peu
particulier parce que euh je me suis dit
ou là enfin
comment comment intervenir et comment
ouais vraiment qui un bel écho en fait
avec ce lieu il est tellement présent
fort tellement beau aussi et et
particulier hein dans son dans dans
d'oire chger d'histoire les murs sont en
pierre ENF c'est vrai que c'est c'est
très particulier et je me suis dit assez
rapidement que j'avais envie de
travailler vraiment directement enfin in
situe directement avec le lieu et de
faire de faire des installations sur
mesure dans le lieu par deux
installations parle des deux
installations les les les les deux
espaces qui accueillent les peintures
donc c'est des espaces qui sont plus
propices je dirais à accueillir des
peintures ici on est par exemple dans
une plus normé enfin voilà une salle qui
est rectangulaire qui classique ouais
voilà qui accueille très bien on peut
rentrer dans cet espace là quand on
arrive dans la retonde c'est une
ancienne chapelle déjà ça ça évoque
quelque chose très différ complètement
autre chose OK et alors justement ces
deux installation alors parlons-en euh
il y en a donc deux celle qui est donc
au centre qui est très impressionnante
comment vous pouvez nous la décrire
alors donc c'est une installation au
sable pigmenté qui épouse euh le sol en
fait en dessous c'est un damier le le
damier de de la chapelle qui estouré de
de ces colonnes
h assez naturellement j'avais envie
d'investir ce lieu enfin ce sol je le
trouvais je sais pas très prop très
propice on dirait un support en fait de
de peinture plus et puis et pu c'est
vrai qu'avec ces colonnes autour le la
déambulation je trou ça invite un
mouvement circulaire ça c'est clair et
même les colonnes rythme en fait ce
mouvement je tr trouve tout autour et je
me suis dit que ce serait vraiment
intéressant pour une fois de grâce au
mouvement du spectateur qui
puisse de
lui-même avoir une expérience picturale
en fonction de là où il se place d'cord
ce qui est pas possible avec une
peinture figée on a Damblé la sensation
en un coup d'œil alors que tout d'un
coup une installation comme ça
qui ouis al après alors on m'a dit 80 kg
de sable et puis on après on m'a dit
mais pas du tout 400000 400 400 j'étais
un petit peu optimiste effectivement à
la base vous pensiez 80 au départ je
pensais une centaine de kilos tellement
dur de de savoir c'est pas votre
spécialité en même temps c'est déjà
c'est la première installation
effectivement au sable que je fais donc
là ça va me donner effectivement un peu
près une échelle pour les futurs s'il y
en a
d'autres disons que je pensais aussi que
la couche serait beaucoup plus fine ah
oui de de sable ouais est déjà fine non
euh bah elle fait quand même 1 cm c'est
c'est dis donc que c'est c'est ass moi
je pensais vraiment que je serais à à 2
3 mm en fait il se trouve que voilà
finalement ça c'est ce qui est
intéressant avec le travail expérimental
quand on travaille ins situ c'est que
c'est que il y a beaucoup de décisions
qui se prennent à ce moment-là donc j'ai
changé un peu le cap en voulant mettre
plus de matière ce qui me permettait
aussi d'avoir le le geste de la main euh
qui dépose le sable en dessous de la
couche de oui voilà parce que je pardon
je vous coupe vous allez commencer par
recouvrir donc la retonde qui est ici
par exemple de de sable voilà et après
vous avez déposé les pigments vous avez
utilisé combien de pigments différents
et ben je dire alors il y a beaucoup de
mélangees de pigments vraiment pour
créer les trans vousz fait avant que
j'ai fait avant et pendant c'estàd que
il y a toute une partie que j'ai pu
anticiper avant et puis sur le coup
entre disons qu'entre deux pigments où
je me disais que le passage allit aller
en fait il a fallu créer au moins deux
trois passages donc en fait ce qui ce
qui donne qui rappelle le travail de de
vos toiles de toute façon voilà c'est ce
passage quand vous expliquez que vous
avez deux couleurs très fortes euh
comment les faire cohabiter et c'est
toujours cette notion de passage et qui
que vous travaillez de transition qui
fait que que l'œil effectivement peut
vraiment rentrer et circuler sans qu'il
soit bloqué en fait d'un passage à
l'autre voilà c'est ça ou qui une
circulation et alors votre votre
question euh c'est est-ce que la la la
peinture peut-être lumière c'est ça
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire disons que je
me suis TER je me suis posé cette
question effectivement euh don déjà
qu'est-ce qu'elle veut dire ça veut dire
quoi cette cette question ce
questionnement
bah pendant longtemps euh le phénomène
lumineux m'a vraiment intéressé dans ce
qu'il a d'accrocheur optiquement en fait
de de vraiment euh de captage euh
captation optique euh du coup je l'ai
beaucoup représenté c'est dire vraiment
le phénomène c'est dire des allau de
lumière et tout ce qui se passe dans la
pénombre aussi et dans les transitions
et après je me suis demandé si au-delà
de la représentation de la lumière
est-ce que même
le donc que la peinture le pigment pur
peut lui-même émettre en fait vraiment
être être lumière en tant que tel et ça
ça change complètement le la manière
d'aborder cette question là et est-ce
que quand quand vous vous travaillez
donc au pinceau avec avec des moments où
la peinture est très pas diluée c'est
pas le mot mais comment vous vous
caractérisez votre geste c'est très
étiré é voilà c'est ça est-ce que
parfois vous êtes surprise vous vous
laissez surprendre par un effet de de
lumière qui apparaît et que vous n'aviez
pas envisagé complètement sachant qu'en
plus d'une peinture à l'autre il y a des
peintures don dont le pigment est
beaucoup plus transparent par exemple
plus prop d'autres plus opaque
ce qui fait que la lumière passe pas de
la même manière donc effectivement on a
surpr j'ai des surprises régulièrement
oui c'est ça qui do qui qui vous qui
doit vous plaire énormément bien sûr
c'est génial bon alors cette
installation donc elle est elle est
magnifique elle est elle est magnifique
V d'en haut
évidemment oui parce que la
particularité c'est qu'effectivement à
l'étage on a de nouveau un point de vue
plongeant sur sur l'installation voilà
et l'autre installation est constituée
de toil peintes toujours dans dans cette
idée de chrom tisme de enfin de couleur
et cetera et bien il y aura encore plein
de choses passionnantes à dire en vous
écoutant surtout ce qu'il faut c'est
venir voir l'expo voilà j'encourage tout
le monde à venir voir cette magnifique
exposition et merci beaucoup Diane benoî
Duray et j'espère à très bientôt oui
merci à vous merci au revoir à tous
merci de nous avoir
suivi